as the novel coronavirus continues to
spread worldwide one common theory is
that the pandemic will die down
when warmer weather arrives looks like
by April you know in theory when it gets
a little warmer it miraculously goes
away hope that's true but the answer is
a little more complicated than that so
why do so many people think that summer
will stop the köppen 19 spread seasonal
patterns are commonplace for many
infectious diseases take the flu for
example we get these big surges of
seasonal flu the peak in January in
February in the northern hemisphere and
the opposite side of the year in July
and August in the southern hemisphere
places like Australia New Zealand South
Africa so the question has been why and
there are three groups of hypotheses
that have tried to explain this the
first of these hypotheses is human
behavior the flu spreads more in colder
seasons when people are more likely to
gather in enclosed spaces and lowers
once people venture outside
however kovat 19 appears to spread much
more efficiently than the flu which is
why strict physical distancing laws have
been enforced but also why you may have
heard experts warned of a rise in cases
once people go back to their offices
schools in normal life the second
hypothesis has to do with your immune
system immune systems have been found to
be better at fighting respiratory
viruses during longer summer days which
also increase the production of the
immunity booster vitamin D so when
summer rolls around people might have a
better chance of fighting off the corona
virus as well and also while you may
have seen suggestions during this
pandemic to spend time safely outdoors
for example on a balcony or in your
garden or even to take vitamin D
supplements but people have focused on
the flus third seasonality hypothesis
the environment that's because both
kovat 19 and the flu are respiratory
diseases that can be spread through
droplets once these droplets have been
coughed sneezed or spat out they are in
the hands of the environment until they
reach a new victim
studies have found that the transmission
levels decrease when the influenza virus
encounters a humid and hot environment
that's the opposite of what we see
during winter where cold temperatures go
hand-in-hand with dry air one study
found that when humidity levels were at
23% after 60 minutes 70 to 77 percent of
the flu virus survived but when humidity
increased to 43 percent only 14 to 22
percent of the flu virus particles
survived in the same amount of time this
humidity change seems to be modulating
the survival the virus such that it
doesn't last as long in the summertime
and it lasts a much longer time when
it's drier in the winter time and that
may encourage and allow the transmission
and hence we see these surges in the
winter time and scientists have a few
answers as to why this is the case the
influenza virus is a simple genetic code
surrounded by a protein layer and a
fatty envelope similar to SARS Cove to
the virus that caused kovat 19 but once
it leaves the body a layer of water
encapsulate sit as well some scientists
believe that in high humidity
environments the virus picks up more
water particles and becomes heavier
which forces it to drop out of the air
lowering the chance of transmission in
dry conditions like in winter
those same droplets evaporate making the
virus much lighter and airborne for
longer but that evaporation has another
positive transmission effect the water
droplet and virus are not alone they are
also joined by salts and one study found
that as the water droplets evaporate in
the dry air those salts are removed
increasing the viruses stability and
probability of transmission but it's not
just humidity that has an impact on the
influenza virus
researchers have found the virus to be
much more robust in colder temperatures
to lasting far longer than when exposed
to higher temperatures
so by now you may be thinking the flu
and Kovan 19 are both respiratory
infections with somewhat similar
structures so surely they will follow
similar seasonal patterns as well but
let's be clear they are not the same not
only in transmission rates symptoms and
death rates but also in the length of
time that they have existed in human
populations this is pretty important to
consider especially when you look at how
virus transmissions slow down at the
beginning of the high seas and you have
some big susceptible pool of individuals
and then as the epidemic grows in cases
climb that susceptible pool is getting
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller so when you get up here at the
top you have fewer people that can get
infected you can think of this like
kindling for a fire the longer the fire
burns and the more fuel is used so the
less kindling you have and the fire will
eventually begin to burn out both the
smaller susceptible pool and the onset
of the low seasons such as the rising
humidity dictate when a diseases high
season begins to turn around that's very
different from a pandemic situation
where you very well may have seasonal
changes in transmission but then that's
having to work essentially all by itself
if there's not a shrinking of the
susceptible pool that comes along with
it for a new viral pandemic like the
current one the susceptible pool is huge
populations haven't developed immunity
to it like they have against say the flu
and when you throw in a lack of vaccines
and treatments the fuel for the fire is
almost endless this isn't to say that
kovin 19 won't be hindered at all by
seasonality one initial study from China
showed decreases in SARS Cove to
transmission along with increases in
humidity however another study wasn't
able to establish that connection
and both should be taken with a grain of
salt in the first place as neither has
been produced in a lab setting yet what
could give a better insight are the ways
in which the four known common human
coronaviruses which are partly
responsible for the common cold react to
seasons so there's evidence from other
coronaviruses and all four of them do
this that they have this pronounced
seasonality so there is this enticing
possibility that has to be considered
seriously and not dismissed that this
novel coronavirus may also have this
property because it's related to them
but notoriously humid places such as
Hong Kong and Louisiana have seen
prominent transmissions in experts
warned that when large groups begin to
gather again we could actually see
another spike in cases which brings us
back to the fact that we may not see
Susan I'll Pat urns just yet but this
doesn't mean that we won't see one in
the future if and when Cova 19 becomes a
more regular presence in populations
there is a strong possibility of it
being seasonal as immunity vaccines and
treatments become more readily available
the susceptible pool will decrease and
the spread will likely increase only
when the conditions are more favorable
and therefore seasonal but again this is
a new disease and these are only
predictions current methods of stopping
the outbreak such as self isolation are
far more efficient than waiting for it
to stop naturally with the weather
you